♪ Hello ♪
- Hello.
Hello.
Come on.
(Adam)
Hello.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Who are they?
- I don't--
Dude, are you pretending
to be gay?
What?
Yeah, man.
I don't want to give them
a reason to kick us out.
- This party seems pretty sweet.
- That's true.
Gay dudes
are like hot chicks.
They only party
with each other.
- Exactly.
- Right?
Hi, I don't believe
we've met.
I'm Joey,
and this is Scott.
Wow, it is very
surprising to me
that we haven't
run into each other,
because we are just
very involved in the scene.
The scene?
(Adam)
Yes.
The...
having sex with
other gay men scene.
Discos.
Yeah, we're three-way gay
with each other.
It's just a shame we don't wear
the same sized clothes, huh?
(Scott)
I guess.
So that you could wear
each other's clothes.
That is the reason.
Right, yeah.
Cool party.
Later, bitches.
Why are they pretending
to be gay?
Are they?
Well, that little one
looks like